I know nothing about it there's enough
to you to spell
I mean we're gonna see if her and Cruz
end up you know taking the dive into
romance land but we won't know until
September 26 8 9 central on NBC there
you go I know nothing I know nothing
about what's going on with Brett's love
life yeah yeah I try to I try my best to
keep a lock on mine no I don't know for
sure we we've started out I know that we
are doing a pretty big storyline with
Casey and Dawson I know just the way it
ended and watching him go forward trying
to navigate the storm of the rocky
relationship and where it's at
and that kind of opens up the door for
storylines I know that you know my
character has always been the one who is
in a bind in his love life and finally
has some some solid ground so it's
offering the ear and the the advice that
I can the sage advice Oh together see
it's like I just let her see Stella ride
ship I'm the captain she's like honey
just say it scream yes honey yeah yeah
he's my first mate the ship is sailing
great
[Laughter]
I don't know that I went out whatever
curveball they throw I'd love to take it
we were just talking earlier someone
asked me about Benny coming back
severide's father and he's it's always
it's always great to have people come
back and I think with with the firehouse
and with some of the storylines that
we're going out on these calls and it's
nice to see interactions with with
family members or or people friends from
high school fairly still has one friend
from my school I can't wait to meet them
yes definitely more crossovers we're all
on one night now Wednesday night one
Chicago Wednesday's so you can
definitely expect more characters from
all three shows intertwining coming all
linen out of each other shows it's gonna
be great it's gonna be great
lots of romance lots of drama you know
all this stuff all the stuff it's
popping in Chicago come party yeah you
can be a detective on SVU then yeah yeah
yeah I wanted to be a dead body that's
actually a hard job yeah because you can
only mess it up yeah exactly three yeah
and they just stopped breathing you're
like like no one gets done playing the
dead body and they go great job are you
blinking are you maybe see you moving